(upbeat music)
- Before we say goodbye,
I have a fun story from the
internet that I hope you enjoy.
This is What I'm Liking.
(upbeat music)
We all know age is a
mentality, not just a number.
So when do we officially
become old is the question.
A middle school teacher
in Southern California
decided to ask his students
this question in a TikTok.
You have to see these responses,
this one says, when you use Candy Crush
(audience laughing)
which I don't know what that
is, so I guess I'm not old.
Here's another,
when you have fun at Home Depot,
you know what?
(audience laughing)
It's a great store.
I love Home Depot and Lowe's, whatever.
One student wrote,
you're old when people have to explain
social media references to you,
they even illustrated it
with a cartoon which was
just even more aggressive.
And my personal favorite,
when you start enjoying raisins.
So, I liked raisins since
as a child, whatever.
Shane is the 7th grade teacher
who collected these responses.
We have him on the line right now
watching on Palm Springs KESQ-TV.
What's up Shane?
- Hi Kelly, how are you?
- Well, I love Home Depot, Shane.
(Kelly laughing)
Which one of these got you the most?
- So for me, I really, in for me
it was a Candy Crush question
simply because I play Candy Crush.
And so here I am at like level 300
thinking that I am killing the
game only to then learn that
that unfortunately makes me
old in the eyes of my students.
But for me, this really
goes back to the idea of why
I love teaching middle school.
It really is a case of
expect the unexpected.
And I think middle schoolers
are really just at that age
where they're starting
to come into their own,
starting to begin that
journey of self-discovery.
And I think that that's a
large reason why so many people
have come to love the
content that we have produced
because it's super relatable,
people think that it's funny
and people enjoy the
perspective of middle schoolers.
- It is really funny,
except Home Depots. Awesome.
Has your TikTok made you
popular now with your students?
- So my students ask
if I am a celebrity now
because of all the viral
videos that we have produced.
And of course I would love
to be paid like a celebrity
but for me it's all just a matter of fun.
I'm always trying to
leverage what is, you know,
current and contemporary
in the outside world
and bring it into the classroom.
I think now more than ever,
especially post pandemic,
one of the biggest issues
that we as educators are struggling with
is simply trying to engage students again.
I think, you know, trying to build that,
the idea of building community,
trying to get kids engaged
and creating an environment
where kids want to
participate and just have fun.
So while I think that,
yes, these videos definitely provide me
some clout in the classroom,
that definitely is really cool.
And at the end of the day
I'm a guest on the Kelly
Clarkson Talk Show.
(Kelly laughing)
(audience cheering)
- Oh my god, Shane, thank you
so much for being an educator.
And junior high can be a tough,
a tough time for teachers.
And my mom, she did
junior high for a minute,
substitute teaching before she
stuck to elementary school.
And that could be a hard,
a hard time for teachers.
So thank you so much, it's
a cool thing that you do.
I'm liking your posts
right now, right man.
Well that's not all though,
our season long partner
pilot pin makers of FriXion,
the go-to race ball pen
of the Kelly Clarkson Show
want to celebrate those
creating fearlessly
and engaging students just like you.
So they're gonna give
you a thousand dollars.
How's that sound?
(audience cheering)
- Oh my gosh, thank you so much.
Absolutely. Thank you.
- Thank you Shane.
And thank you to all our guests today,
Benjamin Grant, Nikki
Glaser, Jake Viramontez,
Dustin Lee and Emily Coffman.
Y'all have a great day and if
it's not, try and change it.